best for the family did you ever get
finesse because I kind of feel like you
run this every girl is like so hard like
everybody's taking else I wouldn't be in
a position to be able to give this
information if I didn't take plenty of
those listen he's definitely been
finessed before and now he's like come
back with a vengeance okay I'll be I'll
be interesting to see what like your
experience with London women are okay
can I be they're not as hot as the girls
in Miami I'll just be honest
yo I'm sorry London chicks I've said
that I'm a point hotter in London I look
it
I'm a solid I'm a solid five in the
United States I get six to seven six to
seven us and it's because London chicks
aren't as hot and if they are they
aren't usually from here I'm sorry
London
I'm sorry
um you know but Miami's an anomaly like
we got the most attractive girls you
know per capita like in any some place
in the world like if you compete like
maybe with Columbia Brazil Etc but yeah
I mean Miami's an anomaly yeah British
girls are not as hot as Miami girls I
mean but yeah it is what it is but we'll
see what happens I mean I'll I'll try to
womanize here and see what happens but
my standards oh yeah well Miami yeah
Miami also the girls
you want to be humbled real quick go to
Miami
okay that's a good thing see it's such a
Negative term but womanizers are
actually the best guys
women eyes I hope you meet some woman
from South really they know what's
attractive they know how to take Raw on
a date they know how to treat a woman
well Etc it's the weirdos that you guys
don't want the womanizer is the ones you
guys want the misogynists those guys I
would argue sexism benefits women great
aim 100 why is that because with sexism
it adds a whole other standard and a
whole other league for women I mean if
there wasn't sexism there wouldn't be a
WNBA or female MLS or we wouldn't have
different standards I agree look at the
fact that they subsidize women's sports
is sexist and I'm glad it happens I
don't think it's fair
but [ __ ] like that's the only reason I'm
here that's the only reason I've gotten
to play as long as I've had
thanks for keeping it real pearl your
content has helped me steer clear of
plenty of 304s got a few feminine low
body count options now
I'm happy for you bro I'm happy for you
sorry I gotta stop saying bro I'm happy
for you sir
sir
you know female police officers are
female firefighters Etc I mean okay I
don't believe in female police officers
I swear to God especially in the UK if
someone breaks in my apartment and they
send me a woman what the f what is a
woman gonna do an average guy can be
both of us up he's just gonna take your
gun he's just gonna
yeah I don't believe in
the UK if I'm not mistaken female
firefighters can fail to test and still
get the job versus a man would never be
able to do that I can't think of
anything sexist that benefits men
besides maybe being able to sleep a lot
of girls and being respected but that's
tough to do
this is that's true what else what other
double standard benefits men
huh
I can't think of any other one yeah I
can't think of one
as a woman 100 very difficult I do agree
like it's a lot harder for men to get
sex but I kind of I don't understand
like why there's so much obsession with
like this body count and everything and
the double standard do you have an issue
that men have an issue with a woman's
body count or do you have an issue with
men wanting a lot of sex a bit of both
really because I kind of feel like you
get mad okay if a woman is sleeping with
multiple men yeah rightfully so but then
if you do the same men and women aren't
the same well how about this let's say
don't really get mad they don't really
get mad I would say like this men just
don't want to wife you after like I
think that men appreciate hoes this is
unpopular opinion men appreciate hosts
they don't respect them but they
appreciate you they're like yeah I
needed
I needed um someone for Tuesdays and
Mondays that's not Main Chick night
clearly
my main chick's working on Mondays and
Tuesdays I need a side chick
in your dating right hypothetically and
you find out that I might have done some
gay porn in the past to make some money
what would happen it'd be over actually
I
I have a question for women
oh my God I have a question what if a
guy did a gay scene
a gay scene who can I call
you go what do you guys think someone
will answer
[Music]
um Anna this is gonna be sad what would
happen yeah I feel like you would break
up with me that's the truth you would
leave me if you found out well because I
would assume that you were gay and then
I'm your Secret to cover up your game my
past matters right no it's not
necessarily like the fact that it's your
past that matters it's just the fact
that you aren't being but it was it was
unattractive that's how men feel and and
you weren't being honest right
how many girls lie about their body
count
women that have a past men are
interested in a woman's past women are
interested in a man's future body count
matters ladies if you're a hoe
you are a hoe by definition and men are
not hoes we are Homemakers that's the
reality so would you not be with a woman
for her family background or whatever
like that because I kind of feel when
you do your background check that those
things are really important when you're
dating someone oh yeah I'd prefer a guy
that had two parents I'm sorry it's like
if you haven't haven't seen what a
marriage looks like how are you going to
do it I kind of want to understand their
mindset yeah there's always exceptions
to the rule but in general
um girls that come from broken homes
typically tend to have very bad habits
girls that don't have a father in their
life typically tend to have bad habits
does this all no but a majority of women
that don't have these things in place
typically don't end up being good women
in general they don't have rudimentary
Basics or if they have trauma in their
life whatever you know trauma destroys
women but it builds men this guy is
insane but I actually think he believes
his own [ __ ] so as a guy it's your
job to find a girl that isn't I'm just
gonna sound terrible and hopefully don't
get cancer from me saying it's tarnished
tarnished yeah it's not really fair to
say tarnished yeah well
well fair but it's true and this is an
unpopular opinion some men can be so
damaged that
it's completely different for men for
women like it affects women worse but my
point is this some men like like it's
not even bad like you could say that
about some men and women wouldn't get
upset like you could say oh he was too
damaged and women wouldn't get upset but
when they say it about vice versa it's
like
because like a lot of people do hold
themselves accountable and do the work
and personal development well yes we do
no no we don't stop it stop it you know
damn well we don't you know damn well we
don't you know
why does he keep laughing at me most
girls don't hold themselves accountable
whatsoever most girls rarely
self-approve if ever most girls think
I'm special I'm perfect the way that I
am I'm a princess I deserve the world
and unfortunately reality kind of smacks
them in the face because they can't keep
a guy long term they just get used for
sex and once modern day women understand
that you actually have to compete you
actually have to show up to that job
interview for that prestigious law firm
in a suit and actually be ready to do
the work you're never going to be able
to keep a job or in this case keep a guy
foreign
have you ever suffered with mental
health no thankfully really if I'm going
through something I'm able to just like
kind of use it as motivation to push
myself through that that time period so
how'd you deal with it through Fitness
I'm guessing yeah that's a big one I was
a division one athlete in college and I
rode it's a very painful sport for
anyone that does it so if you can do a
you know 2000 meter race or a 6 000
meter race then you can deal with a lot
of other stuff you know I will say I
think athletes it act absolutely builds
character and discipline being an
athlete in college men or women like I
just yeah
yeah makes you mentally tough
do you find that you always have to be
tough yeah you can't afford to not be as
a man because the difference is this
when a woman cries on the man's shoulder
that man doesn't lose attraction and
respect for that woman however if a man
cries on a woman's shoulder she's
inevitably going to lose respect for
that man she might not at that moment
she might be there like I got you
whatever but there's something revolting
from a female perspective to see their
man crying now you might not be someone
that's like that but I've had so many
women on my podcast say I thought I can
accept it but when you cry in front of
me it just changed and and the reason
why is because like there's this
visceral like switching a woman's head
it's like this guy's crying in front of
me showing weakness damn this guy can't
protect me and provide for me right even
if it's not true even if it's like a
moment of weakness it can show something
that like oh this guy isn't there
because like women are designed to look
look and that's true like
this is why women give a horrible advice
to men and I'm sure I probably have said
this at some point on some of my
reactions but we this is what we don't
understand like first first you
you think like oh yeah they could cry
but it's like if they do that often you
will leave and you're not gonna be
attracted to his ass and it's not saying
like
never
but like no girl wants a guy that's
crying all that as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible